[Music]
Hi friends and welcome to I'd like to
know some TV. I'm here James Pastor
James Rafferty with Pastor Stephen Boore
and we are I've been told that this is
one of the most popular programs on some
TV. I'd like to know
that's what Marie says.
So we understand that you like to ask a
lot of biblical questions and we love to
answer biblical questions. So this is a
perfect fit for us.
Uh we've got a number of questions here
today. One, two, three, four, five
questions. Usually we just maybe have
one or two, but uh and we may be able to
get through them all. We know questions
have been coming in and we're eager to
get through as many as we can, but we
want to be thorough and biblical and
have uh good backing for all of the
answers. We really don't want to answer
these questions. We want the word of God
and the spirit of prophecy to answer
these questions.
So, uh so we need to get into the
questions, but before we get into the
questions, we need to pray because we
need the Holy Spirit to guide us as we
get these answers. Amen. And I want to
remind you right before the prayer that
if you want to send us questions, you
can do so at tvsumtv.org.
You'll see it on the screen. TV
tvsumtv.org.
Let's pray. Father in heaven, we come
before your awesome throne in the
powerful name of Jesus.
We thank you for your word, a sure guide
in a world that is so confused. And
father as we try to answer these
questions from your word we ask for the
guidance of your holy spirit give us
clarity of thought and give those who
are listening willing hearts as well as
us to receive the word of truth. We
thank you father for the privilege of
prayer and thank you for answering us
for we ask it in the powerful name of
Jesus our lord and savior. Amen.
Amen.
Okay. TV tvsumtv.org. Good. Good. So
they can ask questions that TVsv.org.
They sure can.
TV tvatsumtv.org is an easy way to
Yeah, that's an easy one to remember.
Good.
All right. One, two, three, four, five.
The first question starting at the top.
Is it all right to wash dish dishes on
the Sabbath? Is it all right to wash
dishes on the Sabbath? You know, this
reminds me when I first became a Seventh
Day Adventist. was in 1984,
baptized in November, and I was invited
by my Bible worker to the home of some
Adventists. I had never really been in
an Adventist home before, and it was
Sabbath, and we were having supper. It
was after church, not supper, lunch. And
it was kind of like a, you know, not a
potluck, but you know, there were a
number of people there. And after we got
finished, uh, now I'm a brand new
Adventist. After we got finished, uh,
there were a bunch of dishes there. We
didn't use paper plates or anything like
that. There were a bunch of dishes there
piled up in the sink and uh they started
to to wash the dishes and I don't know
what it was. I didn't know the spirit of
prophecy hardly at all. I was only
familiar with the Bible. I didn't know
what it was, but I I I suggested uh not
to wash the dishes. I said, "Hey, it's
the Sabbath today. We can just relax and
you know, it'll be in a few hours it'll
be sundown and we can wash the dishes
afterwards. I'd be happy to wash the
dishes after that." I'm a newbie, so I'm
not, you know, really navigating well
here. And I wasn't sure how that that
responded to that. But anyway, it it
ended up um opening up an interesting
conversation about Sabbath and what you
can do and can't do on the Sabbath.
And I found myself later on coming
across a very interesting statement in
the spirit of prophecy about
specifically washing dishes on the
Sabbath. Are you familiar with that
statement? I I am familiar and I think
that I might have it here.
Okay, show it to you. Read it to us.
Well, let let me just mention something
else.
Okay.
Um, people need to listen to the voice
of their conscience.
The Bible does not give us a list of dos
and don'ts like the rabbis did.
You can only walk a certain distance and
you can do this and you can't do that.
The Bible doesn't do that. The Bible
deals in principles. Amen.
And we need to apply the principle and
we be need to be honest
when we apply the principle because we
might rationalize.
Uh so uh you know Isaiah 58 gives us the
principle.
Okay. Uh Isaiah 58:13
says, "If you turn away your foot from
the Sabbath, from doing your pleasure on
my holy day, God says,
and call the Sabbath a delight, the holy
day of the Lord honorable shall honor
him, not doing your own ways,
nor finding your own pleasure, nor
speaking your own words."
So there you have principles. What is
meant by your own words?
What is meant by your own pleasure?
What is meant by your own ways?
We have to be honest
with the Lord. We have to pray to the
Lord and say, "Lord, please help me to
apply this principle in my practical
life."
Okay.
Now, let me read you that statement.
Well, before you go there, I'd like to
another Bible verse, the Exodus chapter
20. Now, this is the commandment, of
course, but it says, "Six days shalt
thou labor and do all your work."
Because you know when I read Isaiah 58 I
think about your own pleasure but when I
read Exodus I think about work because
to me dishes aren't pleasurable. Dishes
are
that was exactly what I was thinking.
Dishes are work.
And I like the fact that I have a day
off. I because to be honest with you we
had a thing in our house. I'm not sure
that I always stick to this but the
thing was whoever cooks the other people
wash the dishes. You know the cooks
cooked and they spent a lot of time
cooking. So the rest of the non-
cookooks clean up and of course most of
the time that's me cuz most of the time
my wife cooks and so I get to clean up.
I know you do a lot of cooking in your
home and that's cool. But so for me it's
work and I tell my wife even to this day
just let's just put the dishes in the
sink. I'll take care of them later. Put
the dishes in the sink. I'll take care
of them later.
Um
washing dishes. I I wash lots of dishes
and it's my wife's pleasure
that you wash dishes
that I wash dishes. Okay.
Okay. Uh I don't I don't have the one
specifically about washing dishes, but
it it mentions several other things.
I got that.
Um in heavenly places 151, which is a
devotional book.
The fourth commandment is explicit.
We are not to do our own work upon the
Sabbath. God has given man six days for
labor, but he has reserved the seventh
to himself, and he has pronounced a
blessing upon those who keep it holy. On
the sixth day, all needful preparation
for the Sabbath is to be made. All
purchases should be made, and all our
cooking should be done on Friday.
Let baths be taken, shoes be black, that
means shined,
and clothing be put in readiness.
And then, you know, she adds a caveat.
The sick require care upon the Sabbath.
And whatever it may be necessary to do
for their comfort is an act of mercy and
not a violation of the commandment. But
nothing of our own work should be
permitted to encroach upon holy time. M
uh this reminds me of an experience I
had in Chicago several years ago. That
this is when I began my ministry many
many years ago.
But um you know I received a call from
one of the elders of the church telling
me that there was a family that they
were not Adventists
and they didn't have any food in the
house
and I didn't really have much food in my
house either. So I said, you know, I I
don't have hardly anything that I can
really get in a basket to take to them.
I said, 'But I'll go to the supermarket
and I'll buy some food for them.
And uh so I went to the supermarket on
Sabbath morning uh before I was going to
preach.
And uh I did a holy purchase.
I wasn't doing my own will. I was doing
the Lord's will.
And so um unfortunately, one of the
members saw me go in and come out.
One of the Pharisees.
And um soon the rumor got all around
that pastor Boore does his shopping on
Sabbath
and everybody knew about it except me.
Finally one of the church members
sheeply says, "Pastor Boore, is it true
that you do your shopping on Sabbath?"
I looked at him and I said,
"No, I don't know where that rumor came
from." I couldn't remember because I
never buy on Sabbath.
I No, I don't. He said, "Well, somebody
saw you come out of the grocery store on
Sabbath." Oh, I said now I know.
So I called the person who saw me and I
said, you know, I wasn't purchasing for
myself.
Ellen White says that we should not
allow people to suffer even for one
minute on the Sabbath when we can
alleviate their suffering.
Y
and so I don't think I did wrong. My
conscience told me now if I go if I did
my grocery shopping on Sabbath for me
that's a different story. And I like
that, you know, this this statement and
I didn't quote I didn't write down the
whole thing, but I just quoted a
reference uh with some thoughts from it.
Uh selected messages volume 3, 258.
Tell me if this doesn't bring out the
principles that we've been talking
about.
This is the one specifically about
dishes. It was written in 1901 and it's
258 of selected messages volume 3. It
says that we should not wash if it can
be avoided. We should not wash our
dishes on Sabbath if it can be avoided
because God is dishonored by unnecessary
work.
So there is work that is necessary on
the Sabbath. Alleviating the the
suffering of animals is necessary on the
Sabbath. Alleviating the suffering of of
human beings, whether they're sick or
whether they need food or some, you
know, whatever help they need is
necessary.
Well, you're doing it for others.
Yes.
Not for yourself. And if you've got
dishes that need to be done because
those dishes need to be used to feed
some other group of people or someone
else, that's necessary on the Sabbath.
So I think you're right. The principle
is what we need to look at. We can't
just be a Pharisee and say, "No, you
should never want that." You need to
look at the principle and understand the
underlying principle of why you're doing
what you're doing.
I can give you another example.
Uh when I was in Colombia, I used to go
camping with the master guides. Master
Guides is a big thing down there. the I
mean there's huge clubs of master
guides.
Pathfinders are
uh well master guides is the highest
rank after Pathfinders.
Okay.
And uh and so we went to this campsite
in a place that was uh very tropical,
very hot.
I mean, and there was this crystal clear
river that ran through right through the
middle of the campground.
Where was this?
This was in Colombia.
In Columbia.
And so, uh on Sabbath, I preached a
sermon. We had our khaki shirts on, you
know, which are not actually breathable.
And uh and so everybody was sweating
because they had their uniforms on.
So after uh the service uh some of the
master guides said, "Pastor Boore, would
it be okay for us to go and sit in the
river
and cool off
and cool off?"
Now the Pharisee would say, "Don't you
know that Ellen White says that you're
not supposed to do that on Sabbath?"
Right?
But they were suffering. M.
So I said to them, "Fine,
you can go and sit in the river,
but if I see anyone splashing around or
speaking about secular things,
you're going to suffer the heat." And so
they all went in. They sat there in the
river and they talked about spiritual
things and nobody splashed around. They
didn't play.
I think I did the right thing.
Absolutely.
Why have them suffer
extreme heat and sweating when they
could actually sit in the water and talk
about spiritual things? So, we need to
be practical
and not be ferocal.
Amen.
Another thing, James, which is not
directly in the question.
Uh, but Ellen White even says that we're
supposed to guard the edges of the
Sabbath.
Maybe I can read that statement. We
should jealously guard jealously guard
the edges of the Sabbath.
Remember that every moment is
consecrated. Holy time. Whenever it is
possible, employers should give their
workers the hours from Friday noon until
the beginning of the Sabbath. Give them
time for preparation
that they may welcome the Lord's day
with quietness of mind. By such a
course, you will suffer no loss even in
temporal things. And you I used to
wonder about the the biblical foundation
for that, you know, guarding the edges
of the Sabbath. And I found this text in
Nehemiah 13, which I want to read.
Nehemiah 13:E 19.
Uh, you know, this is after the
captivity
and the merchants of Ty are coming and
they're selling their wares
outside the city of Jerusalem
on the Sabbath.
Okay?
And Nehemiah contends with them
and he actually threatens them
and uh he takes measures to correct the
problem.
Okay? And in Nehemiah 13:1 19,
uh, something very interesting, uh, is
there. Nehemiah 13:E 19.
I'll wait till you get there. Maybe you
can read that.
Nehemiah 13:19.
And it came to pass that when the gates
of Jerusalem began to be dark before the
Sabbath, I commanded that the gates
should be shut and charged that there
should not be they should not be open
till after the Sabbath. And some of my
servants sat at the gates. And some of
my servants set I at the gates that
there should be no burden be that that
no burden should be brought in on the
Sabbath day. Yeah, that's good.
So he shut the gates when
before the Sabbath.
Yeah, before
and they were not open until after the
Sabbath.
So there's an evidence of preparation
before the Sabbath actually begins.
That's good. Yeah, that's a new one for
me.
Okay, we have a we have another
question. We do have another question
and this is um potentially
explosive one.
Oh, is it? Oh, it is. You're right. Yes,
that's right.
It's uh it's the second question we
have. And this one is uh why can men use
pants and not women?
Can women use pants?
So, why can men use pants and not women?
Can women use pants? Yeah, that's that's
one question really. That's one
question.
Yeah, it's it's just one question.
Yeah.
Um,
so there's a couple of Bible verses that
I wrote down in relation to this
question. Uh, the first one was in
Deuteronomy chapter 22. You familiar
with that Bible vers? Yep. Deuteronomy
chapter 22 and verse 5.
Yeah. And I think that this is this
really helped me because when I first
became an Adventist and a Christian, uh
I was really into women wearing dresses
and men wearing pants,
you know, and nothing no deviation from
that. In fact, my wife and I met one of
the first things I didn't know her then
as my wife of course or even my
girlfriend. She was just an attendee and
going to a school we were teaching and
so I was her teacher, so to speak. And
one of the first studies I gave her was
on dress reform
and the importance of wearing dresses.
So Deuteronomy 22:5,
"The woman shall not wear that which
pertainth unto a man, neither shall a
man put on a woman's garment, for all
that do so are abomination unto the Lord
thy God."
And I used to think, you know, well,
pants are for men and dresses are for
women. Yeah.
But you know, when you go back to the
Bible, everyone wore robes. Right.
That's true.
And yet God wrote this at that time. So
there must have been a distinction
between the robes that men wear wore and
the robes that women were wear or wore.
And even in in some some cultures today,
like if you go to India or Pakistan,
I've been there several times,
you find men wearing robes, you find
them wearing, you know, gown type stuff,
but they've got a pant underneath that's
a little different than definitely
different than the woman's robes. Same
with, you know, India. So there's still
a distinction there.
Yeah. So, it can't be that because I
think in the western mindset, we just
automatically think pants are for men,
dresses are for women, and not realize
there's there's a lot of pants that I
wouldn't wear because they're not made
for a man, right?
They're made for a woman,
if you know what I mean.
And there are pants that women can wear,
I think,
if they're modest.
Yes.
That uh you you know that they're for
women. Um, you know, by the way, in
Scotland, near the place where you were
born, men wear skirts.
I was born in I was born in the States,
though. I want to tell you that. I was
born.
But you have some Irish background.
I was raised in London. Yeah, I was
raised. Raised in London.
Yeah. My mom was born in Ireland. Yeah,
that's right. Yeah.
They call it a kilt, right?
They do. Yeah. You wouldn't want to call
it a skirt if you were over there, I
don't think.
I wouldn't want to wear those one of
those things in Fresno in December.
No. Or in Scotland even. It's cold. It's
cold in Scotland.
Yeah.
So dress
uh when God talks about this dress is
not defined by pants or skirts or you
know dresses. It's defined by what who
it's made for.
Yeah.
What because you wouldn't see a woman
wearing a kilt over in Scotland.
Uh that they wear dresses, they wear
skirts, but not a kilt. The kilts for
the men. It's a men's dress,
right?
Yeah. So I think that's the principle
here.
Yeah. And you know, I think that um the
the gist of Deuteronomy 22 and verse 5
is that a man should not use the attire
of a woman with the intention of
confusing people.
Yes.
About what their what their gender is,
right?
And vice versa.
In other words, it's forbidding being a
transvestite
basically.
You know, man wanting people to think
that he's a woman and a woman wanting to
make people think that she's a man,
right? Uh so uh I want to just read a
statement from uh the book uh child
guidance page 427.
Okay.
Uh where Ellen White speaks about the
need for there to be a distinction
between uh male
dress and female dress. Um there is an
increasing tendency
to have women in their dress and
appearance as near like the other sex as
possible and to fashion their dress very
much like that of men.
Wow. What what would she say today?
But God pronounces it an abomination.
In like manner also, she's going to
quote Paul now that women adorned
themselves in modest apparel with
shamefacedness and sobriety.
Then she continues, God designed that
there should be a plain distinction
between the between the dress of men and
women
and has considered the matter of
sufficient importance to give explicit
directions in regard to it. for the same
dress worn by both sexes would cause
confusion. There's a thing
and great increase of crime.
Yeah. What would she say right now? And
I really believe that that we are living
in a time when this is a very sensitive
subject. Uh it's it's difficult to talk
about this in a political correct
society, right?
I think it's important for us to
recognize that this is one aspect of the
the principles of morality that God has
in his word. And sometimes we want to
isolate this from everything else. Like
for example, we would say, "Well, that's
that's something we shouldn't do and
that's terrible they do that, but gossip
is okay. Maybe it's more acceptable."
But it isn't, is it?
There's nothing that's, you know,
outside of the realm of morality.
There's nothing that that that is
acceptable with God. Whether it's
gossip, whether it's crossdressing,
whether it's a violation of the
principles of of a man and a woman, or
whether it's the violations of the
principles of honoring your parents.
Yeah.
In Romans chapter 1, Paul puts all of
those in one category. Just goes through
the whole list of them all the way to
the end.
And I think all of us in Romans chapter
3, he says, "All of us are guilty."
Verse 19, the law comes to us and all of
us become guilty. The difference is
between those of us who are believers,
who are followers of Christ, who are
believers in God. The difference is is
that we acknowledge,
right?
We don't try to justify. We don't try to
defend. We don't try to say, "Well, this
is the way I was made. This is the way I
was built. These are things that because
all of us have those inherited and
cultivated sins that are genetically in
us, so to speak, but we simply
acknowledge, oh, wretched man that I am.
Who who can deliver me from the body of
this death?" Whatever the thing is that
the Bible points out, none of it is puts
us in a worse category than anyone else.
We're all sinners saved by grace, but
all of it needs to be given to God,
whatever it is.
Yeah. And you know, I don't I don't know
if you're aware of this, but um just
recently the 117th Congress was sworn
in.
Mhm.
And the first vote that they took was
that in the chamber,
yes,
you could no longer use the word father,
the word mother, the word brother, and
the word sister.
Because somebody might get offended,
right? And so now you have to speak of
parent
or you have to speak of sibling.
Now as Adventists we we would not be in
harmony with that.
Not at all.
Because the Bible says that we're
supposed to call God our father.
Yeah.
And the bo Bible says honor your father
and your mother.
So there's a certain place where we
cannot be politically correct no matter
what society and culture wants us to be
when it's a matter of principle. Right.
And for me that is a matter of
principle. Absolutely.
Now, there's some there are several
principles when it comes to dress. Maybe
I can mention these.
Um, our dress needs to be neat.
Ellen White emphasizes all these.
Our dress needs to be clean.
Our dress needs to be economical,
not cheap,
right?
Economical.
Good.
It needs to be simple,
not gaudy and extravagant.
It needs to be healthful,
not super tight, you know, that uh
doesn't promote health. It needs to be
modest.
Uh it needs to be of good quality.
And it needs to be distinctively male or
female.
And also she says it should be well
fitting.
Not too tight, but it should be well
fitting. We shouldn't look like a
scarecrow where the the clothes just lit
on us and we're just like this, you
know.
Right. Right. So yeah, very important
principles.
Yeah. And I think that they speak to the
God that we follow. You know, the way we
dress, the way we carry ourselves, our
department speaks to the God, you know,
our heavenly father. We want to
represent him well.
Amen. Well, let's go to our next
question.
Next question. Question number three. If
Jesus was our example in all things, why
can't we eat fish?
Which, you know that, interestingly
enough, uh the implication of course is,
you know, Jesus ate fish and we know
Jesus ate fish. In fact, he probably ate
Passover lamb, too. Um, so if Jesus is
our example, why can't we eat fish? And
I I think when I when I read this
question, the first thing I say to
myself is, well, you can eat fish if you
want to. I mean, you know, there's it's
not a sin to eat meat. If it was if it
was a sin to eat fish, then we'd be in
problem having a problem because Jesus
ate fish and, you know, he's our savior.
He he's sinless. And uh and
interestingly enough, we were at a
wedding not long ago and there were a
number of people there that were, you
know, not um 7th Day Adventists or even
Christians. And so the host I was doing
the ceremony actually. So the guy we
were marrying and and his wife, they
wanted to cater to their family who
weren't and so they had some salmon
brought in and uh and my wife who's Mrs.
health reformer
decided to taste some of that, you know,
just because she's always liked salmon,
even being raised in Adventist. My wife
was born and raised in Lomolinda,
California. You don't get any more
Adventist than that,
right?
And she hardly ever has eaten any meat
in her whole life. And my my children
know this. And so, we're at this
wedding. We're at this um what is the
wedding after the wedding? The
the reception.
The reception. Yeah, there we go. And
she has a little salmon. And later on
she calls my son and you know he knows
we did and she tells him you know and he
says too much information too much
information I can't cuz he he knows her
as the you know Mrs.
And you know you do and and so she he
was just like mom you know
and it was really uh interesting that uh
I could tell you another story. We could
talk about this a lot but
the point is is that it's not an issue
of you know like people have said to me
I'm a vegetarian. They say oh is that
because you know your church doesn't let
you eat meat. I said no that's because I
don't eat meat. I choose not to. I've
got the information before me and I
choose to eat a vegetarian diet. It's
the best diet for you. It's been proven
not only biblically speaking, but it's
been proven by research, you know, to
this day.
Right? You know, for an Adventist, it's
it's different than a non-adventist.
Um, Ellen White tells us that we need to
discard all flesh food,
including fish,
but then people say, "Well, Ellen White
contradicts uh the Bible because the
Bible says that Jesus ate fish." Mhm.
The way that I resolve that issue is
that when circumstances change,
Mhm.
God's counsel changes.
You know, fish in the times of Christ
was not the same as eating fish today
because of the contamination.
I give this example. The city of
Karakas, where I grew up in Venezuela,
has a river that runs through it. It is
the sewer of the city. Wow.
But I've seen pictures from a hundred
years ago where people used to go there
on Sunday and go swimming.
Wow.
And they used to fish in it.
But now you find signs everywhere that
says do not swim. Do not fish. Danger.
Well, there's no fish in it anyway, but
danger.
So, so why did they encourage people to
swim in the river
100 years ago? And they don't and they
discourage people from doing it today
because what used to be clean is no
longer clean.
Yes.
And so good example. And so Ellen White
is saying, "Yes, God allowed to eat
fish. Once upon a time, Jesus ate fish,
but things after 2,000 years of sin
have become so contaminated that it's
best to leave fish completely."
It's kind of like when the Pharisees
asked Jesus, "Is it lawful to divorce
your wife?" And Jesus said no. And they
said, 'Well, why did Moses say you could
write a bill of divorce? And he said,
well, because of the hardness of your
heart. But from the beginning,
at the beginning,
it wasn't so.
Right.
So, going back to a certain time, it
wasn't so. In God's original diet, in
the beginning was a vegetarian diet.
And that needs to be our standard.
The beginning.
Yes.
Our standard is not a plan B
or plan C.
Our standard is a plan A.
Because when we go to the end, we're
going back to the beginning. Revelation
21.
Well, folks, our time has flown by. When
you're having a good time, time flies
by.
Um, I want to remind you to please send
us your questions. Remember the address,
tvsumtv.org.
And we hope that next time you'll join
us for more questions and answers. May
God be with you. Thank you for joining
us.
Heat. Hey, Heat.
[Music]